19 options uh notice the order of their  appearance agender androgynine bigender  demigender and then cis male and cis  female  now if you're wondering for some reason  demigender means somebody who is one  gender but not fully that gender so  perhaps a demigender is 82 man and the  other 18 is comprised of uh you know  other ingredients but the striking thing  about this array of options  is not what makes the list but what  doesn't notice what's missing the  options for man and woman not there  these categories have been erased  instead sasha is a biological female who  knows that she is a female and  identifies as what she is has to settle  with the term cis female but cis is an  invented term made up by the lgbt left  with the express purpose of making  normal men and women seem like one mere  variation among an infinite array of  equal if not superior options